I think one more people are waking up to
the idea of challenging the traditional
school system and if you're gonna go to
college you need to go to college get
your data and do something with it in
the same day what's that believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna look at
what Grant Cardone has to say about the
traditional education system working for
other people and becoming your own boss
also if you want to know a grant and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you have to go
build self-confidence basically the
traditional school system is because
parents are lazy lazy it's a place to
send them so that we don't have to be
with them I mean if everybody just got
honest it's it's it's okay don't you go
to school it's good for the government
they like all the money it produces
tremendous amount of money that gets to
go to that so they can do whatever they
do with that money everybody agrees
worldwide the school systems are
terrible except maybe in certain parts
of Asia in America it's awful even the
private school the best schools I mean
all the way up to college all the way up
to the big schools so people are you
know in college people are studying five
hours a week that's not that that's no
study time 60% of the kids are not
getting out of college in four years
forty percent are still not out after
six years
it's an awful waste of money in time we
think so we want a home school we hey
what do we want them schooled in you
know what the experiences of life are
more valuable than just something that
comes out of a book we believe and I
think more and more people are waking up
to the idea of challenging the
traditional school system we had a
resume sent to us the other day and the
guy started spouting off all the schools
he went to and I'm like he'll never make
it here it's crazy I held it against him
because he was highly educated
I have many young followers and they're
asking me this question should I finish
my school or should I start a business
uh-huh I have this dream to start a
business show that way that I finish the
school and then I chased my dream or do
I chase my dream and just forget about
this school so I think I think that I
would tell them look you shouldn't do
either you know you should go get a job
yeah you should get a job working for
someone that's in in the space that you
want to be in it's already going down
the road right that has experience that
has gunpowder money that had that has
courage and is written taking risk
already I I think that a lot of people
that start in business they shouldn't
that should know I look I got guys
working for me Jared you're gonna make a
couple million dollars for series a
millionaire already he's been with me
seven or eight years Ryan the pilot he's
gonna he's working in the real estate
space these guys could never get on
their own as fast is working with
somebody like me
yeah so people have this idea that you
have to be your your own your own your
own boss is ridiculous I'm not even my
own boss I don't work for myself that I
work for a lot of other people so
there's no such thing as about the boss
mm-hmm you know I work for other people
I have to be on time at other things
there's you're always gonna be answering
to someone the Queen she's she answers
to people yeah everybody answers to
someone so there's no such thing as I'm
gonna be my own guy if that's why you
want to get in a business for yourself
definitely the wrong thing to do but
staying in college like if you could do
college in two years then do it and get
out and work on the weekends but if it's
gonna take you four or five or six years
of income unless you're a doctor unless
you're a very very specific trade
professor maybe yeah well but what's he
gonna do for the world
yeah he's gonna work at the place that
some dropout funded
you
now we got a special bonus clip of
grants advice for young entrepreneurs
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that I want to know what did you
think you agree with grant what do you
think about the traditional education
system let me hear thoughts leave it
down in the comments below
what's your mindset on young entrence
today with the social media realm and
kind of what would you be doing today if
you could go back with this current
social media well first of all you know
if you're doing drugs if you're doing
drugs of any kind then you're not you're
not gonna take advantage of anything
going on so you got to have focus what
hey what am I gonna do this is an
unbelievable time unbelievable
opportunity right now for you guys to be
connected to almost anybody you want to
be connected to that's the good news the
bad news is you could be connected to
almost anybody in the world and that's
the bad news because because the what
happens is you can get so much content
from so many different people the 57
guys you you listen to if if the people
that follow you listen all 57 of them
they're more likely to do nothing then
then a bunch because there's gonna be
conflicting data like I know some of the
guys some of those guys I love they're
unbelievable and there's other guys that
that if you listen to them and then
listen to me you're gonna be like hmm I
don't know which one to do you know if
you're gonna listen to your dad and
you're gonna listen to me you're
probably not going to do anything
because you're gonna be in doubt because
I'm gonna tell you to go I'm gonna tell
you to move faster and your dad's your
dad as a parent is going to tell you be
careful take small steps take your time
and I'm not going to tell you that so I
would just tell you guys that are 1718
teenagers man look don't use drugs I'm
telling you these drugs I have personal
experience it's not a moral issue I'm
not trying to be your daddy here
if you're smoking weed man you have no
chance of winning in the marketplace I
will kill you so if you're smoking weed
and I'm not I'm gonna beat you to the
close I'm gonna beat you to the money
I'm gonna beat you in the game number
one number two you know you need to you
need to be really narrow about who
you're gonna study if you're studying
people looking for mentors you don't
need you don't need three mentors you
need one guy that you can study he's
your guy or gal and you go deep on that
dude and number three doing winds doing
beats all the education in the world I
spent 17 years in schools I got a
college degree got an accounting degree
I got a cousin of mine that says you
shouldn't bash college did you go no I
said well I went I know I have the debt
you did
go I know it is I'm not telling you guys
not to go to college I'm saying look if
you're gonna go to college you need to
go there with a purpose and if you're
gonna go to college you need to go to
college get your data and do something
with it the same day don't wait until
four or five years after you get out of
college so doing is the best education
in the world yeah for sure I mean even
like but then we're gonna have here a
lot of us have the YouTube channels that
will do a lot of stuff with different
industries and a lot of my friends a lot
of people I know just comes from the
fact that like they just didn't know
what to do they just started doing and
then it came from the actual doing the
unsaid so you know when you're doing
when you're doing you start learning a
lot of things that you didn't know
you're gonna figure out your brand
you're gonna figure out your pitch
you're gonna figure out what works what
doesn't work what people like what they
don't like yeah and if you're an artist
you want to do a lot you want to do a
lot of art because then you're gonna
discover what people actually like
you're gonna learn stuff that you just
can't learn in the classroom not doing
[Music]
if you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
if you want more grant check out the
ultimate guide to becoming a millionaire
video we made on him the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you come up short
in your goals set them higher you cannot
get to where you want operating and
thinking with poverty behavior